well the foreign Borough International
Air Show has resumed after a three-year
Hiatus due to the pandemic
it kicked off with a major deal
announced between Delta Airlines and the
American aircraft maker Boeing Delta
said the order for 100 Boeing 737 Max 10
aircraft will help modernize its Fleet
and that it expects the max planes to
reduce fuel consumption by 20 to 30
percent
the order is great news for Boeing which
has recently struggled to compete with
its European rival Airbus
well for more on this deal I want to go
to our correspondent at the New York
Stock Exchange Jens quarta now yens
Boeing has really struggled to keep up
with Airbus after its Max 8 was involved
in deadly crashes in 2018 2019. now this
Delta deal is the latest in a series of
737 orders does this mean Boeing is
finally moving past those crashes
well Christie it definitely is welcoming
news so there's no doubt about it
especially as Delta has not ordered any
uh planes from Boeing for quite some
time and the last biggest order is about
more than 10 years ago
um also what is quite astonishing is
that we've seen this big order despite
that those Max 10 planes do not even
have official approval yet in the United
States
um and there's still a certain chance
that maybe a Boeing has to cancel the
production all together but now we have
this big order in total Boeing has more
than 700 orders for those 737 Max 10
planes so that is definitely some good
news but yeah it's going to take some
time to fulfill those orders and the
slim chance actually that Boeing might
not get the approval in the next couple
of months might be one reason why the
stock of Boeing actually didn't do that
much um here in the Monday session
Jens quarter thank you so much
well our correspondent Jack parrick is
at Farm Bureau despite the chaos
currently plaguing the industry he saw
quite a lot to be excited about
the new Boeing triple 7x a giant
and it's one of the star attractions
here at the farnborough International
Air Show the event was ignited by the
news that Delta Airlines had placed a
firm order for 100 of the triple 7x's
smaller brother the Boeing 737 Max a
deal worth over 17 billion euros the
ultimate customer the aviation Market
has been severely hit in the past two
years you know there's no hiding that's
there's no secrets but it it is an
industry it's also in recovery and you
need positive signs of that recovery and
what better example than the Boeing deal
that you just talked about
elsewhere at the show the scaling up of
commercialized delivery drones was
brought into focus with the British
business secretary announcing a 300
million euro investment in drone super
highways good news for developers and
manufacturers here who say initiatives
like this will clear up a messy
regulatory landscape
especially for us we have clients for
all over the world asking different
questions and we in in many ways we we
don't know what to say because we don't
know all those laws and everything that
that is now in position so we think that
this is starting point for drones also
significant attention landed on the
Prototype air taxis they may look
futuristic but the companies making them
reckon they'll be fully operational by
2030 even
well let's cross to our correspondent
Jack parrick who is in Farber for us
great to see you and to see the planes
behind you uh what's the mood like there
because we all know about the
well-documented problems facing Airlines
and airports at the moment but what
about exhibitors at farnborough
yeah that's right Rob this is a very
interesting type of air show obviously
the the priority for the exhibitors is
to show the best of the global aviation
industry but passengers around the world
and especially here in Europe are seeing
enormous lines and cues and troubles and
cancellations at major airports like
London Heathrow like Amsterdam skip hole
and in fact all across the continent so
the mood here is trying to show what the
best of the new and future business is
but an understanding that they need to
focus on what's what's really important
which is keeping people moving at the
moment I think what's interesting from a
very initial scan of the exhibitions
here is that a lot of them are not only
about the sort of traditional Airline
Industries your boeings your lockhead
Martins and all of these companies but
also there's a lot of different
exhibitions with things that look sort
of like small flying cars essentially
very futuristic and I think that's
something that farmer is trying to look
in to to make sure it bleeds on the on
the progress of the aviation industry
you mentioned Lockheed Martin we can see
some military jets behind you there
obviously are also a key bit of context
that this is the war in Ukraine now is
that's something that's that's altering
how the exhibitors are approaching this
year's farnborough
yeah it definitely is as you can see
yeah there's some some fighter jets
behind me there's a lot of military
helicopters uh just over there the
question is sort of what does this mean
the context of the the war in Ukraine we
know obviously that NATO has said that
Ukraine's military should be swapping
into Western military uh supplies so
that it's interoperable with NATO rather
than the old Soviet uh equipment that it
traditionally uses but Ukraine's
military is unlikely to be buying these
sort of airplanes instead they you know
they're using uh different um sort of
aircraft anti-anti-aircraft missiles
essentially that are being supplied by
Western allies in a large part so the
question is what does it mean for for
this industry because these planes will
be being sold to to the British Military
and to the U.S military but there is as
you say there's a sort of context here
there's an understanding that that war
in Ukraine against Ukraine is having an
impact on every single industry because
it is a large part of why Aviation is
struggling as well well and just very
briefly if you can normally billions of
dollars or euros worth of deals are
struck during these these air shows is
it looking the same this year
yeah so the the real focus is on the
deals that Boeing the American Airlines
aircraft Builder is is signing now we
understand that between Delta and
Lufthansa around 50 and 15 billion
dollars worth of airplanes being sold
including the
777x behind me which is sort of the big
enormous star of this show that
everybody is uh is coming to see all
right jack parrack at farnborough for us
thank you very much